[Music]
have you guys compared notes about being
these you know kicked butt female when I
was working on Avengers I got to know
brie Larson pretty well and alright you
know a little bit as much as you can on
a film and and her and I talked about it
and of course she's gonna be the next
title female superheroes she's gonna be
Captain Marvel and then I'm sure that
you know this will be the beginning of
many many more titled Marvel films yeah
Widow Scarlet Witch I mean I don't know
who's next or who's gonna get it but
like it's not it's just the beginning
yeah it's true I hear they've gotten to
work together brie and Evangeline
Captain Marvel and the wasp have gotten
to work together someday someday maybe
someday maybe that would be cool well
I'll tell you I have had the opportunity
the privilege to get to know brie Larson
I think she's the perfect Captain Marvel
I think that you know first when she was
cast for it I was surprised but then I
realized of course I'm surprised you're
always surprised at who Marvel cast for
there where there's superheroes and then
once I got talking to her and I and I
got to know her convictions in her
strength and her fierce warrior spirit I
was like oh that's why I can't yeah yeah
[Music]